look the main issue is the intention the  intention to not be in a relationship no  one's disregarding how you feel about  what you want to want to do but you're  the arrangement that you have in your  head so that's it yeah that's it you  don't want to be in a relationship  a child but you still I don't want to  belong to somebody  like where is the obsession with  possessions  this is straight cut is that not you  wanting to possess them you want to  control that I don't it all comes down  from everything that we talk about on  these shows I have another conclusion  that actually men do like a woman men  like to be like oh no no no no there are  so many different relationships